Harry's mum calls him a miracle baby and
although most parents might say that in
Stacey broadmeadow's case it's based
more on fact than feelings at 33 Stacy
was diagnosed with a rare form of cancer
that meant having her own biological
child might not have happened I
experienced some very dull pain within
my appendix area and some spotting in
between my periods but nothing that you
would think
ouch or nothing that kind of hindered my
day or anything like that but because I
always wanted to be a mummy I always had
at the back of my mind something might
be wrong here or it might impact any
potential fertility
in the future so I went to the GP and
then he did the usual checks sent me for
an ultrasound and sent me for some
Bloods that then I went for an MRI scan
then I went for a CT scan and then it
kind of grew faster picked up the
momentum Stacy's cancer is known as PMP
and affects tissue around organs in the
abdomen her treatment involved
chemotherapy and the removal of both her
ovaries I had to deal with the cancer
diagnosis then I had to deal with
fertility might definitely be at risk
but luckily it was slow growing so I was
given the opportunity to go for egg
harvesting when I ended up with just two
embryos at the overall stage that's when
it hit me like wow this is this might
not ever happen and then the first
embryo was transferred and I miscarried
and that's when I thought wow this is
literally now
didn't like it will either happen or it
won't away we went and here he is
so yeah he literally is a miracle Stacy
was treated at Christie Hospital in
Manchester where her medical team say
early diagnosis made a huge difference
we're just so happy for her we really
are it's just incredible and you know it
gives hope to all the patients out there
that this can be done you know it's it's
just brilliant for Stacey I'm so proud
of her Curry is now five months old my
world's been flipped upside down
completely but for the better
we live every day we are going to go on
lots of Adventures we've got lots of
family and friends that support us we're
on yeah we're in a little bubble of Love
Katrina novatozi Sky News Manchester